we're going to begin with the news and
that is the long-awaited verdict in the
murder trial of disgraced attorney Alec
murdaugh when the jury finally got the
case just yesterday it did not take long
for him to be found guilty on all counts
including the murder of his wife and son
in June of 2021. Nikki Batiste has been
following this trial since it began and
she is once again at the courthouse in
Walterboro South Carolina where Murdoch
is going to learn his fate in just a few
hours this morning Nikki good morning
what's the atmosphere like there
Tony good morning well I think it's
still a lot of shock at how quickly the
jurors came to this verdict and Alec
murdaugh will be back in court this
morning for his sentencing he faces 30
years to life in prison the guilty
verdict came after a juror was dismissed
for discussing the case with at least
three people as a result an alternate
was subbed to help decide Murdoch's fate
in a dramatic finish to this gripping
case
guilty verdict verdict guilty verdict
guilty signed by the four-person jurors
came to a decision in less than three
hours Thursday finding Alec murdal
guilty of killing his wife Maggie and
Son Paul in addition to two counts of
possessing a weapon during the
commission of a violent crime we would
make a motion for a mistrial murdahl's
defense attorneys asked to overturn the
verdict a move judge Clifton Newman
rejected the evidence of guilt is
overwhelming and I deny the motion
murdal appeared stone-faced as he was
escorted from the courtroom in handcuffs
pausing to look at his surviving son
Buster who appeared to have no reaction
moments earlier Buster seemed to hold
back tears as each juror confirmed their
decision our Criminal Justice System
worked tonight it gave a voice
to Maggie and Paul Murdoch following the
verdict prosecutors shared their
reaction it doesn't matter who your
family is how prominent you are if you
do wrong if you break the law if you
murder
then Justice will be done in South
Carolina earlier in the day the defense
presented its closing arguments
dismissing the state's claim that murdal
killed his wife and son to gain sympathy
before Decades of alleged Financial
crimes came to light totally illogical
irrational and insane those are words I
wrote down for someone to kill their
loved ones when their criminal conduct
is being exposed in their rebuttal
prosecutors reiterated that murdal had
admitted to a pattern of lying in his
testimony in particular about being at
the crime scene minutes before the
murders took place you don't lie about
that that's not a mistake
that's not a mistake jurors agreed
unanimously finding murdal guilty nearly
two years after Maggie and Paul were
found dead we can't bring him back but
we can bring him Justice
in remarks after the verdict the judge
told the jurors he applauded their
decision before murdal is sentenced
today we will likely hear Victim Impact
statements the defense could appeal the
guilty verdict but even if they were
successful Murdoch could still face life
in prison for his alleged Financial
crimes some of which he admitted to
during this trial Gail
Nikki Batiste who has been on the case
from the very beginning great job thank
you Nikki thank you very much